one of the chief bamboozlers is cringe
Jean-Pierre here she is talking about
how the lgbtqi plus elementop Community
is under attack
him put up the force field
eventually
if by literally lady you mean that the
trans Community is attacking the
lesbians because they're trying to turn
them into men and they're attacking the
bisexuals because they're trying to turn
them whichever way the buys are going
that day or they're trying to turn the
young gay boys into women then yes I
would say that the gays and the L's and
the B's are under attack if you mean
anything else beyond that which is
obviously what you actually meant then
you are just a liar and a fraud and a
buffoon nobody's coming for the lesbians
have any could you Google this real
quick have any lesbian rugby leagues and
there's tons of them out there have they
been closed down anywhere are they
coming after the lesbian rugby leagues
are they coming after the gay uh what do
gay guys do in their privacy you know
with other gay guys I don't know like uh
juggling have they come after the gay
jugglers or any of it's just absolutely
insane or line dance no line dancing the
gays line dance that's more of a cowboy
thing I don't know anyway there's a lot
of gay cowboys too by the way it's just
insane
[Music]